Lara à table
à table je te dis
les mains sont lavées
bonne nuit ma princesse
tu peux venir une histoire s'il te plaît
un petit chaperon rouge
il était une fois une petite fille la
plus jolie qu'on est se voir sa mère en
était folle
et ce soir un peu naze
le loup et les sept chevreaux
un jour dans un pays lointain une
vieille chèvre qui avait 7 chevaux et
qui les aimait comme chaque mère aime
ses enfants
c'est bien ça
il était une fois un prince qui voulait
épouser une princesse mais une vraie
princesse
il fit le tour de la terre pour en
trouver une mais il avait toujours
quelque chose qui clochait des
princesses il n'en manquait pas mais
était tête des vrais princesses
papa
je t'aime très fort
moi aussi je t'aime très fort
oui maman
oui je l'ai amené à la danse
ne t'inquiéter comme ça ça va on se
débrouille très bien tous les deux ouais
j'ai prévenu la maîtresse
salut
vous n'avez pas de nouveau message vous
avez un message archivé pour le
consulter tapez 1
et maintenant madame la direction
et j'arrive ah oui couche pas tout de
suite je suis là dans un quart d'heure
je t'aime très fort je vous aime tous
les deux très fort
vous n'avez pas de nouveau message vous
avez un message archivé pour le
consulter taper un
peu Madame la Directrice
je suis là dans un quart d'heure je
t'aime très fort je vous aime tous les
deux très fort